le deuxième but monégasque c'est
l'international junior qui va le marquer
la voici la réaction des joueurs
monégasques demandé par leur entraîneur
jean tigana et leur président jean-louis
campora le deuxième but monégasque c'est
l'international junior thierry henry qui
va le marquer la voici la réaction des
joueurs monégasques que demandé par leur
entraîneur jean tigana et leur président
jean-louis campora
ce match entre deux modeste équipe de
niveau régional va rester longtemps dans
les annales
on joue la 89e minute santa cruz mc au
maillot rouge se crée une superbe
occasion qui se termine sur le petit
filet jusqu'ici rien d'anormal sauf que
le ramasseur de balle est un supporter
de santa cruz en fait et pour lui pas de
doute un l'enfantillage qui aurait dû en
rester là mais dans un grand moment de
confusion
l'arbitré de la rencontre madame
néolibérale voit le ballon derrière la
ligne et décide contre toute attente de
valider but et pour les commentateurs
brésilien quitte ce but qui forcément
suite à cette erreur incroyable madame
bio libera risque une suspension longue
durée comme quoi on n'a pas toujours
besoin d'un plus petit que soi
et puis là la sida alors est ce qui
n'est vraiment contente
mais là il n'y a pas eu de contact pour
la bonne raison c'est que c'est milla
jovovich qui a fait une faute les quais
de la mer écarter le ballon et est ce
que bhl a passablement énervé
certainement quelques coups de poing et
alors donc l'expulsion pour base à
revoir
et puis la laci dans alors est ce qui
n'est vraiment content là il ya eu
contact pour la bonne raison c'est que
c'est milla jovovich j'ai fait une faute
qui est de la mer écarter le ballon et
skoblar passablement énervé certainement
raymond domenech raymond domenech qui
lui a d'autres soucis il prépare son bac
et je crois que les deux comptant la
finale est enfin quel final que vous
appréciez vous êtes juniors vous avez 19
ans on a l'impression que vous donnerais
n'importe quel adversaire ce serait la
finale de la coupe du monde vous seriez
toujours aussi calme en mayenne espoir
pour demain
n'est ce pas s'étant approché voilà
aux joueurs la main sur le coeur pour
écouter l'hymne national tout le monde
avait remarqué hier soir ce geste de
très grande ferveur patriotique
personne n'imaginait qu'il était la
conséquence d'un coup de téléphone
cette image de l'équipe de france avec
tous les joueurs le main sur le coeur en
en hommage à leur président et à ce
qu'il représente
j'ai trouvé que c'était beau personne
n'imaginait qu'il était la conséquence
d'un coup de téléphone un appel reçu
quelques heures plus tôt par zidane au
bout du fil
gerald dahan animateur de radio et
imitateur il se fait passer pour jacques
chirac est 20e avec la mort d'une femme
ce que vous voulez ce président monsieur
gérard la marseillaise et vous pouvez
mettre la main sur le coeur mais ils ont
évasive on le fera ce président j'ai
pour moi
j'ai trouvé que c'était beau c'est
dommage que ce soit parti d'un canular
mais souvent ça des résultats positifs
donc maintenant je peux je peux je peux
en riront bons joueurs raymond domenech
car lui aussi a été victime de la
supercherie puisqu'il a confié aux faux
président est secret d'ordinaire très
bien gardé j'ai posé cette envie qui
joue ce soir parce que c'est secret
jusque jusqu'à la mi-match donné la
feuille de match donnait tout à fait
dans ce monde c'est vivre thierry henry
la ga thuram et je sais pas trop je veux
mettre en débat les navettes au début
l'image de l'équipe de france avec tous
les joueurs la main sur le coeur j'ai
trouvé que c'était beau
les bleus s'entraînent mondial n'a pas
encore commencé mais déjà le président
chirac occupe le terrain à toute
l'équipe de france je veux dire je suis
avec vous tous les français sont avait
arrêté les buts comme barthez les halles
ont fait les autres en rêve
j'aurai beaucoup élevé à 3 go jacques
chirac english
ce footballeur de 19 ans a trouvé ses
repères place du dom il s'émerveille
stagiaires à l'as cannes il y a deux ans
encore il avait pour idole france green
card une vedette de milan thibault qu'un
gosse de 19 ans aux portes de la gloire
mais rassurez-vous la tête restera bien
sur les épaules et ses potes du centre
comme ici mômes aux séries les joseph
qu'il ne retrouvera toujours avec
plaisir
pas mal ces défilés de mannequins avec
vos dires de ceux qui le côtoient tous
les jours il al'étoffe d'un futur grand
mais pour les autres ce transfert des 30
millions bilan est plutôt surprenant
alors pourquoi les dirigeants une année
sans doute chercher
et oui il en sera de même pour tous ses
copains du centre qui ont désormais un
nouveau club fétiche le milano et les
gosses un peu de calme où je me fâche
hockey
on avait été trahi par des journaux tout
au long des années et la france en
famille qu'elle avait une grande équipe
de france qu'elle avait des grands
joueurs et qui dépend des le maillot
français et aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas
envie de pardonner
non je ne pardonnerai jamais jamais je
pardonne à des propos qui s'adresse
directement au quotidien sportif
l'équipe accusé levé vous bien sûr on
s'est senti visé puisqu'elle a nommément
c'était notre journal qui est
aujourd'hui je dirais le sol assumer ce
que plein d'autres gens d'ailleurs on
écrit il ya deux mois et il faut assumer
on s'est trompé fois su mais vous
faudrait mais jacquet bravo c'est bourré
vous avez eu raison
l'équipe fait aujourd'hui son mea culpa
on peut y lire en première page
nous avons de formidablement belle
raison de reconnaître que la méthode
jacques est un pays
moi je pense que c'est surtout je dirais
cette communion qui s'est passé avec les
joueurs depuis longtemps on avait
beaucoup de complicité
depuis longtemps on avait mis en place
cette force et cette intensité cette
générosité et enfin le public passé nous
avons connu puisque a été extraordinaire
c'est que au fur et à mesure que les
matches se jouent à l'équipe de france
était de mieux en mieux oui parce qu'on
avait pris à capital de confiance
extraordinaire on avait été trahi par
les journaux tout au long des années et
la france en formule qu'elle avait une
grande équipe de france qu'elle avait
des grands joueurs et qui dépend des le
maillot français et aujourd'hui vous
n'avez pas envie de pardonner
non je pardonnerai jamais jamais je
fabrique
chaude la finale de la coupe d'afrique
des nations entre le ghana et la côte
d'ivoire en verve à la brosse ivoirienne
pour la présence de pelé le ghanéen sur
le banc des délégués et expulsion du
protestataires ivoiriens une première
période qui devient à partir de ce
moment ajouté très agitée trop agitée
deuxième période on pourra rêver lorsque
traoré est lancée avec intelligence sur
le flanc droit
traoré astucieusement tente le lob sur
le gardien gagnant en deçà un beau geste
technique et la savane rebondit sur la
transversale
une occasion ivoirienne contre une ode à
na lorsque richard dabou après un petit
lot cette loi est contré in extremis par
voix mêlées le gardien ivoirien
toujours 0 à 0 le ghana qui dans la
dernière minute du temps réglementaire
aurait dû trouver le chemin des buts sur
cette frappe terrible de yeboah hélas
encore une fois sur la transversale
prolongation puis tirs au but
interminable séance des tirs au but
c'est en 12e tir que la côte d'ivoire
l'emportent suite à cette frappe manquée
de bafouer le gagner 00 11 tirs à 10 et
première victoire de la côte d'ivoire
aux sites d'afrique des nations
cherry d'algos assure regrouper les
forces vives du football français est
constitué ce que l'on appelle la bande à
hidalgo c'est à dire que tout va bien
pour y figurer cette équipe de france si
pratiquement pas d'échec une
qualification pour la coupe du monde est
ce que vous avez de la chance je crois
qu'il faut une grande part de chance ou
au moins une part de chance dans tout ce
que nous entreprenons dans le sport est
là il ya eu certainement bon coup du
sort mais je crois aussi c'est parce que
je la chance de rencontrer des des
jeunes gens de qualité sur tout ça et
puis toujours dans le domaine des faits
divers il y à l'incroyable tentative
d'enlèvement contre l'entraîneur de
l'équipe de france de football michel
hidalgo alors qu'ils se dirigeaient en
voiture vers bordeaux ce matin il a été
agressé par deux inconnus hidalgo a pu
les désarmer et coûteux le raconter ce
qui s'est passé à maurice olivari mais
on m'a demandé de descendre et de suivre
à quelqu'un qui est menacée avec un
pistolet de le suivre jusqu'au petit
bois qui se trouvait à 50 mètres là j'ai
attrapé le canon du revolver et j'ai
réussi à
elle reprendre il est tombé par terre
gelée repris avant lui et quand il l'a
vu ça il s'est sauvé ils sont tous
remontés en voiture pour pour démarrer
s'enfuir
s'ils ont eu le temps de vous préciser
les raisons de leur agression non non en
voyage je leur disais mais qu'est ce que
vous voulez dites moi ce que vous voulez
dans l'eau dans ce cas là on se demande
où est le sport que vient faire le sport
dans tout cela et et je n'y voyais plus
d'intérêt cette grande joie du 16
novembre s'estomper s'effacer d'un seul
coup puisque ont repris le dessus
le sport et puis aussi parce que j'aime
me retrouver au milieu des joueurs et je
crois qu'on a besoin de continuer notre
action pacifiste de réunir les gens
plutôt que les diviser voilà le départ
aura bien lieu demain pour l'argentine
une reprise de volée santé
alors que vraiment on s'attendait
absolument pas ce qu'on pense d'elle
puisse reprendre cette base dans les
conditions où il se trouvait cela va
certainement lui donner confiance et
pendant les dernières minutes qui
restent à jouer
fontaine va peut-être faire des
étincelles matin
bien repris de volée
le deuxième
évidemment quand un choix a le moral il
fait des choses extraordinaires
bon alors la deuxième raison alors la
deuxième raison c'est que d'abord les
joueurs étrangers ne me connaissaient
pas d'où un peu la surveillance qui
qu'elle tirait mon copain qui m'a
facilité la tâche parce que ont marqué
plus tôt kg anthony et kopa qui était
connu dans le domaine international
alors que moi je n'avais pas encore
semer preuve puisqu'il n'y avait pas eu
l'occasion que je défie ce merveilleux
jamais l'arc de triomphe n'aura si bien
porté son nom
une fête incroyable la france à
l'unisson des bleus d'aimé jacquet
pourra citer obtenions des tricolores
revenir champion du monde français de
l'histoire
wall e cell ou au sol ont réussi là où
avaient échoué les copains kopa ou la
bande à platini 3 0 face au brésil sous
l'oeil des géants de l'équipe de france
un million et demi de personnes sur les
champs elysées
toute une nuit blanche pour voir la vie
en bleu
une telle marée humaine c'était du
jamais vu depuis près d'un demi-siècle
le même drapeau pour tous et à chacun
son héros
non
oh non nous nous en voulons et non toute
l'équipe de france
tous les jeunes et je fais un cadeau le
plus beau cadeau prix plus élevé meetic
pense est la foule demande aujourd'hui
forcément
il
j'ai aimé jacquet c'est robert pires je
remarque un peu
je met quatre mains c'est quand même pas
mal
chez les gt et robert pirès je prends
part qu'un peu
jean mais quatre enfants c'est quand
même pas mal
je vais donner davantage et la nage
on ne pas perdre
alors dites ont dû arrêter mieux
ouah c'est la première fois que du vide
je dieu je m'investis l'émotionnel mans
dans une coupe du monde et je vis un
moment exceptionnel de folie je savais
pas très simple qui d un super
ne vous inquiétez pas si nous vous nous
voyez tout en vert c'est pour marquer
aujourd'hui de cette couleur
particulière ce jour ce mercredi 12 mai
1976 sans vouloir faire cocorico nous
savons que ce serait quand même pas mal
si saint-etienne gagné ce soir face au
bayern de munich à glasgow pour cette
finale de la coupe d'europe de football
mais permettez nous quelques clins
d'oeil d'humour même si vous n'êtes pas
passionné par le football
mais voyons tout de suite où l'on en est
pour les deux équipes à quelques heures
du match
si on les avait laissés faire
aujourd'hui aux champs elysées les
supporteurs pour la grande parade
organisée par france inter
l'avenue des champs serait devenue la
venue de saint-etienne
la statue de clemenceau aurait été
remplacée par celle de rocheteau et le
métro georges 5 aurait été rebaptisé
station des frères révelli la triomphale
défaite des footballeurs de
saint-etienne les gaulois s'était
entendu dire un jour
malheur au vaincu eh bien les astérix du
ballon rond en 1976 sont couverts
d'honneurs pour avoir perdu 1 à 0 devant
légèrement couvert d'honneur mais aussi
submergé par l' enthousiasme délirant
des supporteurs d'occasions toujours à
la recherche de dieu du stade
les sociologues pourrons nous dira un
jour pourquoi la france aime tant les
héros malheureux mais c'est vrai que les
verts on était plus célébré que s'ils
avaient gagné leur finale de la coupe
d'europe
et
permis cette équipe jeune et dynamique
un homme en blanc qui se transforme tous
les huitièmes dans 23e homme
la mort qu'istres l'homme en noir il
s'appelle robert burck il a 28 ans il
est licencié en chimie physiologie et
possède un doctorat de 3ème ce que je
crois qu'ils seulement de l'antigène de
volvo cars je pense qu'on a un plan qui
les rapproche les deux villes voulaient
rich et yves colette
on fera le titre de la fatigue norris
menacée note sérum à 6128 robert wurtz
ne fait que commencer son dur
apprentissage d'art vivre bien sûr il en
est à sa huitième saison
mais en réalité il ne fait que débuter
sa première saison en tant qu'arbitre au
fait des vols
une claudia bottin qui lançait sous la
lune ont quitté le palais de lille
graminées que l'été enchanteur sous la
voûte azuré avait enfanté et même les
zozos ailleurs et le vieux laboureur et
lapins charmer par les violons des
bennes ont laissé les labours et les
chemins glacé par ce lourd manteau blanc
que les dieux dont je tais
à 27 ans ces deux des principaux atouts
d'auxerre et de l'équipe de france pour
y parvenir ne sait pas nager et il
continue à l'entraînement il effectue un
travail spécifique à raison de deux
séances par semaine avec le souci que
s'améliorer encore
comme tous les gardiens de but vas tu as
besoin d'être en confiance pour donner
le maximum d'eux
pour ce poste la concurrence n'est pas
en effet bénéficié bien nouveaux prêts
il sait très bien que demain tout peut
être remis en question
oh
présenté dans cette unité
on en retrouve l'élite du football
français 25 % de l'emploi du temps est
consacré à des exercices bien connue en
particulier les défilés opa ou encore le
traditionnel parcours du combattant
preuve 250000 appelés du contingent
je pense que des gentils qui sont
athlètes de niveau ou des gens qui ont
déjà un métier
et qui doivent rendre une année à
l'armée c'est vrai que ça peut poser des
problèmes maintenant c'est pour tout le
monde pareil on est bien obligé de
donner cette envie de donner cette année
d'armer une année au cours de laquelle
il a radu et les autres continuent
d'exercer leur métier de footballeur
environ quatre heures d'entraînement par
jour sous l'autorité d'un technicien
réputé et à forte personnalité
mon iphone pour solidaires mais bon de
la pop
équilibré qui permet de mieux s'exprimer
sur le terrain c'est tout ça toute cette
ambiance ici c'est toute sa dame bien
c'est tout c'est ma copine isabelle
raconte qu'en amical en c'est si loin
c'est effectivement c'est ça c'est la
campagne c'est la nature c'est toujours
mieux le king eric cantona taille de m
86 le poids 80 niveaux pour de forme et
c'est souvent la plateforme oise ça va
pour moi c'est oui cette année ça va à
témoin cette passe lumineuse pour ferrer
qui a déboussolé les nantais
et quand on lui parle de la grande
équipe de france eric reste sur la
réserve il n'a que 20 ans
si elles incluent par l'équipe de france
c'est vrai problème mais moi c'est sûr
que si ça arrive ça me ferait plaisir
quoi si ça arrive et ça m'a fait plaisir
mais mais pour moi c'est probable même
par la suite si le jour je viens il ya
trop tout ça c'est pas ça qui comme
quand vous tournez matata je pense pas
si vous adore le foot c'est un peu moins
rapide qu'en coupe d'europe
il n'y a d'ailleurs plus aucun but même
si on a bien compté à la fin sur une
échappée solitaire du numéro quatre un
beckham locales armées finalement il n'a
pas trompé est la sagacité du bol voilà
voici les équipes seniors au japon
fourchette d'âge entre 80 et 93 ans il
paraît que cette division est en pleine
explosion là-bas d'abord parce qu'il a
beaucoup de retraités puis en plus il
adore le foot mais du coup ils ont joué
leur propres coupes
voyez la finale c'est un peu moins
rapide qu'en coupe d'europe il n'y a
d'ailleurs plus aucun but même si on a
bien compté à la fin sur une échappée
solitaire du numéro 4 le beckham locale
mais finalement il n'a pas trompé est la
sagacité du gol voilà et la défense
surtout pour mieux portera comme ça
parce que si on continue à répéter comme
ça et d'atteindre le bêta
rocancourt pendant cinq ans et en
particulier un footballeur
à quelques minutes de la fin du match
alors que les commerçants mené par 2 à 1
sur une erreur de la défense darby trop
siffle penalty aucun chamaillard one
aurait voulu rater ça les privilégiés de
chamalières ayant pu assister à
l'entraînement avait paraît-il beaucoup
ri
mais aujourd'hui c'est du sérieux elle
est membre d'une mairie athletic club
ainsi que ceux du dynamique commerciale
jouent comme des professionnels enfin
presque
le match de football qui a eu lieu hier
à chamalières dans le puy de dôme
pourrait trouver sa place aussi bien
dans la rubrique sportive que dans la
rubrique politique la vedette en était
dans les faits monsieur giscard
d'estaing qui jouait demi centre dans
l'équipe de la municipalité contre
l'équipe des commerçants de chamalières
c'est vous qui parce que j'ai un accent
est parti d'un goal etc dans des refuges
à protéger des loups justement que
meilleur les communistes ont coulé
voulait arrière et notre part de robin
la partie d'année
en-avant de travail bien sauvé au centre
jordan tout à l'heure il disait quand
même le football le col roulé
l'accordéon c'est un peu beaucoup de
folklore pour assainir les finances
quand j'étais un petit peu choqué par sa
remarque n'ont pas roulé sous la pluie
quand même et je crois pas à l'éliminer
bien sa part considéré que ce sont des
personnages à part ce sont des hommes
comme les autres qui exerce à comprendre
évidence et beaucoup de français qu'il
faut français qui pensent comme lui j'en
ai vu quelque chose à faire le plein
derrière et je vois pas pourquoi on ne
fait pas un français comme les et en
particulier un footballeur moyen comme
lui
rencontre de football
insolite que celle qui se déroulera sur
la pelouse du stade de gallician ce
samedi à 17 heures l'équipe du gallia il
sera opposé à l'équipe pascal du gallia
également dans ce petit village gardois
dont un excellent cru a fait la
réputation
on attend ce match avec impatience
curiosité et sympathie mais oui vous
entendez bien les onze membres d'une
même famille les onze frères pascal ont
été ou sont licenciés au gallia cinq ou
six d'entre eux figurent encore sur les
feuilles des matches de l'équipe senior
qui opère cette saison tandis que les
deux plus jeunes évoluent en équipe
cadets la famille pascal est composé de
11 garçons et quatre filles l'une
d'entre elles régine jour au football
elle fera partie de l'équipe qui opérera
samedi en qualité si je veux dire de
douzième homme est le treizième homme
sera son neveu thierry
ça se passe à andorre et il s'agit de
football et regardez bien l'action du
gardien de but
elle est très inhabituel
alors vous avez apprécié le geste de
finale ou gagner du binôme bien on ne
sait pas vraiment si pourtant tout le
monde
parce qu'il est convenable de dire
publiquement que j'aimerais faire un
cadeau à thierry roland lui qui a
toujours été très gentil et très avec
mon club
leur toubib autorisée j'aimerais faire
un cadeau à thierry roland lui qui a
toujours été très gentil et très avec
mon club
lorsqu'on est autorisé et même pas du
chantage
donnez moi si le tiercé s'appelle
aujourd'hui le prix rieussec à longchamp
c'est en hollande à brady quinn que deux
équipes se sont formées et lutte pour la
conquête du ruban blanc descendent par
les ailes percée d'avant-centre blocage
de défenseurs
le ballon ce n'est décidément pas rond
après les coups de pied et coups de
poing
voici les rembourrages de pare chocs
avec l'auto ball
celle de ted remaniement et aux comptes
pour les joueurs de football fatigue et
ne serait ce pas une fin de saison
pratique
inventeur sportive vient de trouver une
nouvelle machine permettant aux
footballeurs de perfectionner leur
technique
l'assiette des tireurs aux pigeons dont
le coeur est sensible et remplacé ici
par un ballon le corner par fait à la
portée de tous
aussi pour éviter la charge d'un
adversaire fusée fauteuil pour dentistes
chaises pour bébés non aux pays bas un
inventeur sportive vient de trouver une
nouvelle machine permettant aux
footballeurs de perfectionner leur
technique
l'assiette des tireurs aux pigeons dont
le coeur est sensible et remplacé ici
par un ballon le corner par fait à la
portée de tous
aussi pour éviter la charge d'un
adversaire
voici un système de portillons que les
parisiens amateurs de métro n'ignore pas
puis pour terminer entraînement au jeu
de tête les footballeurs seront ils
remplacés par des robots en l'an 2000
m
taylor fut problème les locaux vont
faire cavalier seul la cohésion est
bonne des actions sont bien liés et
sedan commencent à plier
dix minutes après le second but locaux
vont trouver une nouvelle fois leur
récompense
diallo refus problème les locaux vont
faire cavalier seul sa cohésion et
pommes des actions sont bien liés et
sedan commencent à plier
dix minutes après le second but et le co
vont trouver une nouvelle fois le
récompense par jacquet 3 à aimé jacquet
techniquement comment jugez-vous vos
adversaires de demain nous aurons serre
sont très bons surtout physiquement
donc il faut s'attendre à un match très
physique de moi surtout militaire où les
problèmes sont assez difficiles à
résoudre
non
le tellure reste à faire dans
l'application c'est vrai qu'on ne s'est
pas laissée par le facétieux devenir un
jour officiellement il va falloir qu'ils
développent encore beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus parce que je pense que
s'il veut faire la carrière de café que
les fait automatiquement dont il va
falloir qu'il fasse beaucoup jaune ou
est il des fourmis dans les jambes au
point de vouloir reprendre sa place
d'arrière latéral
heureusement non car voyez le résultat
ce jeune joueur qui se joue du lieu de
supplice et son jeune fils qui à 20 ans
vient de signer son premier contrat
professionnel avec le fc grenoble
il n'imaginait pas que le nom de
djorkaeff revivre dans le football
professionnel par l'intermédiaire de son
fils youri youri qui lui bien sûr pense
faire une aussi belle carrière que
partiellement
je pense à être meilleur suivi des
entraînements parce qu'on dit pas
bonjour pas le mot nous on joue pas la
même époque
mais bon j'espère faire aussi bien c'est
moral de football et preben une grande
famille
bon j'ai pas eu à m'en occuper longtemps
parce que tout de suite il a montré ce
qu'ils voudraient il a montré qu'il
était ici pour faire des travaux chez
lui c'est sa faculté à jaillir devant
l'attaquant proprement quoi qui va vite
j'avoue je crois qu'il a tout pour
s'imposer au plus haut niveau
s'il est un défenseur qui a de l'avenir
et qui va devenir nuit à mon avis un
jouet repeint touristes capable de
marquer des but en championnat cette
saison comme ici à furiani contre bastia
par exemple ou comme son premier but en
coupe d'europe c'était face au spartak
de moscou en 1996 après une passe de
chiffon visiblement et on n'y croyez pas
d'autant que son rôle est plutôt de
défendre les cages de son équipe que
d'attaquer c'est le désert cool en se
régalant d'écouté miles davis qu'il
adore liant se rappelle parfois qu'à
l'âge de 9 ans il a quitté la guadeloupe
pour arriver avec sa famille en région
parisienne lui le premier bébé de
l'année 72 de pointe à pitre puisqu'il
est né un 1er janvier a toujours été
sportif du cross-country au foot il n'y
avait qu'une balle pour un premier
contrat professionnel signé à 20 ans à
monaco un jeu physique mais en
respectant l'adversaire pour arsène
wenger qui l'avait désigné comme
stoppeur c'était déjà une qualité
majeure pour ces nouveaux entraîneurs il
aurait d'autres
cool
bonsoir à tous thuram en demi finale tu
gagnes en finale qu'elle pourrait être
aujourd'hui la devise de l'équipe de
france de football
c'est là à ce moment je me suis évanoui
oui je me suis venu parce que je
m'attendais pas
alors en fait il n'ya même pas de joie
c'est l'étonnement que je pense qu'il
faudra prendre au moins 25 ans encore
pour que je marque deux buts match moi
je dis mais qu'est ce qui t'arrive jeudi
route et mais marcel mais marcel niger
moins idiot de ce qui se passe je dis
moi j'en sais rien ce qui se passe
c'est là autour du rond-point situé
devant n'gog attrape jeu toute
l'histoire commence il y à 19 ans face
au 25 de la rue du champ de blé sur une
dalle de béton
les premiers exploits qui a commencé à
être au-dessus de nous la cie du lot
physiquement déjà il avait une bonne
technique déjà tout est nul comme du
pire à courir il couvre la technique
très technique il a après après sais pas
mais qui nous prend nous reste elle-même
gagner de police ne gagne plus que
certains mais je reste le même souffle
way et c'est le cas c'est le cas quoi la
médiatrice est faite sur ce crime et
recouper quand je suis toujours le même
il reste par ailleurs adoption en clair
la merci des scoops et voilà le seul
luxe que c'est permis nicolas on est
loin d'une trappe et du rond point ici
non encore un petit gars de banlieue qui
pourrait bien porter haut les couleurs
nationales
décidément ça devient une habitude ça
fait toujours du bien de revenir attrapé
à samantha peu le moral c'est pour ça
que les dés que j'ai deux trois jours je
rentre directement tu te souviens de
leur prénom et tu es tu es capable de
leur délivre un message aussi à ses
copains ouais bah je pourrais passer les
mangera à karim djamel hakim ça mais à
tout le monde de van gogh
j'espère que je verrai bientôt
moi je m'étais préparé on avait un match
décisif face à la yougoslavie avec les
espoirs et j'étais préparé pour ce match
là et on m'avait appelé en catastrophe
le lundi en me disant qu'il fallait que
je reviens une équipe de france donc
c'était un peu tout nouveau jeu
débarquer dans un nouveau monde n'était
pas spécialement prêt pour ça ma
première vraie sélection c'était après
quoi quand j'ai pris le bon wagon c'est
le match amical en suède et là où il y
avait quand même un michel platini
sélectionneur et il avait la possibilité
de choisir entre je sais pas moins 50 de
joueurs que j'ai appris à l'ancienne et
un jeune l'ancien c'était bernard pardo
et puis le jeune c'était didier
deschamps j'ai eu cette opportunité là
le président décide d'interrompre le
protocole et demande le renvoi des
équipes aux vestiaires
jacques chirac exige également des
excuses immédiates de la fédération
c'est inadmissible et inactifs
dans les tribunes la situation est
diversement apprécié des supporters
continuent de sifflet d'autres entament
la marseillaise
la plupart attendent avec impatience le
début du match il est 20h40 hier soir le
speaker du stade de france vient
d'annoncer l'hymne national
dans les tribunes les champs côtoient
les siffler tout au long de la
marseillaise notamment du côté des
supporters de bastia
jacques chirac mais quelques instants à
comprendre ça siffle je m'en vais
annonce-t-il au président de la
fédération dans la tribune officielle
c'est la confusion le président décide
d'interrompre le protocole et demande le
renvoi des équipes aux vestiaires
jacques chirac exige également des
excuses immédiates de la fédération
le président a décidé de prononcer une
déclaration en direct à la télévision
tel que six responsables ont cru devoir
siffler la marseillaise ce soir au début
de ce match
cette inadmissible et inacceptable
malgré les instances sportives les
grands événements deviennent des lieux
d'expression et de contestation les
supporters ne se gêne pas pour y
manifester plus ou moins finement leur
hostilité envers des équipes des pays ou
des individus hier soir jacques chirac
ne l'a pas supporté
ce soir lorsqu'il a pénétré sur la
pelouse du vélodrome ça bien sûr penser
à tous ces événements à son sud ouest
natal à lavelanet à son père citoyens
d'ovalie et ancienne équipe et de walter
spanghero cette sélection en équipe
première c'est ce qu'on appelle
communément la chance de sa vie
la scène se passe cet été à font romeu
lors du stage d'avant saison
pascal olmeta s'entraînent sous l'oeil
bienveillant d'un jeune homme tout frais
débarqué de toulouse fabien barthez 21
ans à peine quelques matches en d1 mais
c'est sûr beaucoup de talent la preuve
les dirigeants olympiens en débourser
une petite fortune pour s'attacher ses
services
l'ancien gardien du tfc sera la doublure
de pascal olmeta une chance pour ce
joueur qui en début de saison passée
évoluer en division d'honneur de l'an
dernier j'avais weinstein j'ai fait 28
matches en 1re division donc je me
donnais jusqu'à 24 à 28 en première
division mais la chance d'avoir un grand
club donc je vous dis faut être patient
et continuer à bosser
on n'a rien à perdre
le psg en finale donc finalement paris
nous appartient
marie boudou c'est vrai que paris est
annulé
paris et j'ai une facture bien de moi et
francis borelli va embrasser la pelouse
voilà moi je pensais comme aurait pas
pris son bon vouloir et parfait
d'espagne abla aurait dit voyez
exubérant au milieu de ses hommes
la soixante cinquième finale de la coupe
de france revient au paris saint germain
à
mascotte de cette coupe du monde a été
présenté aujourd'hui et elle s'appelle
footix
non
oui mais pour le cheval c'est maintenant
le grand départ vous attendiez à cet
accueil de noailles à hyères
oui justement ça me surprend pas
l'accueil parce que non maintenant je
dois le mériter et je pense de leur
faire confiance et d'arriver à à gasques
au vainqueur et ramener la coupe
d'europe à saint-etienne avec l'aide des
verts
ça fait qu'assurer major roule le moral
est bon il est pas et la patrie de coups
et j'y arriverais
l'auteur de buts qui vont suivre un
français l'an passé il marqué pour
valenciennes cette année ils marquent
pour bruges en france les avant-centres
s'appelle halilhodzic carino ville corps
question de mentalité et de moyens
l'auteur de buts qui vont suivre jean
pierre papin un français l'an passé il
marqué pour valenciennes cette année ils
marquent pour bruges en france les
avant-centres s'appelle velogic carreno
villefort question de mentalité et de
moyens à l'étranger je pense passer même
si tôt en france y font plus confiance
aux jeunes que le taux français
les français veulent les avancées qui
sont expérimentés tu manges a marqué pas
mal de buts 1 en première division en
équipe nationale le fragment pas de
changer
il n'a pas oublié ses copains ou non
plus ne l'ont pas oublié quand on le
voit quoi on dit qu'il a commencé là et
tout c'est bien parti pour nous si on
tape des petits fous de la laisser dans
le champ un malin plaisir moi salut je
me présente c'est un wiltord meilleur
buteur du championnat et pourtant je
suis pas un buteur passé de la 1re
division de district amateurs à la
division 1 professionnelle en cinq
saisons voici l'histoire merveilleuse de
sylvain wiltord
sylvain est un monde de banlieue issu
d'une famille de huit enfants de la cité
des fauvettes à neuilly sur marne
aujourd'hui trois reines il est deuxième
buteur du club avec me bulls à 21 ans il
a conscience d'avoir eu beaucoup de
chance il sait aussi ce qu'il doit à la
banlieue pour la banlieue s'est pas
servi finalement ouais ça m'a servi à
m'endurcir je pars à connaître des
situations les plus difficiles et à les
accepter plus ça m'a servi à prendre
pour la suite
bouge de là
on pense toujours au co patois mais pour
se sortir vaut mieux mettre les copains
de côté et puis après les revoir quand
on a réussi
c'est ici qu'il a grandi c'est aussi ici
qu'il a contracté le virus du football
bien avant l'âge de pouvoir chausser les
crampons car papa halde aujourd'hui
entraîneur fut il n'y a pas si longtemps
un des plus solides footballeurs de la
région
le secret de ces fameux coups francs qui
l'ont rendu célèbre
des mannequins en mousse et des heures
en tête à tête avec le gardien de l'as
nancy lorraine jean michel moutier ses
coup-francs voulait préparé depuis
longtemps
oui je les prépare à ces deux furent
longtemps mais je crois que ces derniers
matches et quand même de la réussite
parce que sur un coup franc j'ai marqué
un but en quatre matches assez répété
j'ai vraiment depuis longtemps non parce
que ça veut c'est venu comme ça j'avais
certaines qualités pour brosser
violemment les ballons et je crois que
j'ai une certaine facilité qui technique
pour la mettre un peu où je veux donc
que si on réunit les deux je crois que
je peux marquer beaucoup de buts
sans club à michel platini c'est nancy
c'est là qu'il s'est épanoui c'est là
aussi qu'il a connu ses premières joies
et ses premières craintes d'un principe
je suis sous contrat jusqu'en juin 79
mais sûrement à nancy jusqu'en juin 77
après c'est vous rêvez pour l'instant
plutôt à saint-etienne ou à l'étranger
au point de vue résultat on rêve à
saint-etienne mais je pense pas que
saint-etienne est déjà deux mois tandis
que l'étranger bon ben c'est leur rêve
de tous et qui voulait jouer les grands
clubs
normal
et puis tout de suite tirées et nous
pour revenir sur ce bulgarie france
ces incidences ces incidents on vous a
retiré attend le sparadrap que
jean-michel le lieu où vous avez mis en
travers de la bouche pour vous expliquer
bien sûr on le sait on ne va pas le
répéter mais il est peut-être bon quand
même de le faire l'arbitrage a été
particulièrement déplorable et voire
injuste a proposé des sanctions qui tout
semblait accès vers l'équipe de france
mais vous même vous êtes peut-être allé
un peu loin que pour vous c'est réglé si
monsieur foot vous irez le trouve et on
a je pense pas qu'il viendra passer ses
vacances en france de toute manière ça
je ne pense pas qu'il ne viendra et bien
attendu un peu partout mais alors oui à
ce propos certains laissant entendre
qu'il y aurait passé ses vacances en
bulgarie faudrait tout mouvement les as
qu'il faudrait le prouver enfin c'est
qu'il est quand même assez curieux de
constater que la première mi temps son
arbitrage avait été bon faut le
reconnaître enfin moyens moyens et que
en deuxième mi-temps alors ça a été un
arbitrage catastrophique enfin bernard
père et moi sommes de relativement jeune
journaliste mais enfin il y avait des
glorieux anciens avec nous qu'ils ont
vécu pas mal de campagne
je pense par exemple à robert vergnes de
l'équipe ou à roland mais semeur chef
des services sportifs du figaro bah oui
n'avais jamais vu ça de leur vie alors
ceci explique peut-être cela voyous oui
mais on peut être la plume plus légère
en tout cas oui chérie je souhaite que
tout le monde oublie cet incident est qu
on vous retrouve s'il est l'âme aux
habitudes toujours pleins d'esprit et
caustique quand il le faut mais avec les
mots qui conviennent
vraiment pas peur de le dire monsieur
foot vous êtes un [ __ ]
et